it's nearly one year to the day
since joe biden's inauguration and thus
far his time
wandering around the white house has
been a disaster on all fronts
he failed to crush the virus which he
was never going to do but he promised it
but he is crushing in-person learning
for kids the economy is tanking and
inflation is soaring the supply chain is
worse than ever bare shelves biden it's
a real thing just go to your local
grocery store
right after the show
our southern border wide open and crime
as you know is out of control so far the
only thing joe biden has built back
better
is the taliban
so it shouldn't be a surprise to anyone
that team biden would like a chance to
forget this whole last year and just
start over fresh
here's their solution only dc could cook
up this solution
joe
2.0
according to nbc consider the source
senior administration officials are
looking to launch a public reset and
rebrand of joe biden
saying quote there is a recognition to
change the dynamic what a quote
uh you think well let's be honest can
you really teach an old dog new tricks
especially when that dog has been in
politics for 47 years
and can he learn those tricks before the
red wave wipes out his majority after
the midterms here now fox news senior
political analyst and smart dude britt
hume brit thanks so much for being here
joe 2.0 your reaction to that attempt
well i'm not expecting a full reset
anytime soon pete i think what we're
going to hear tomorrow in the
president's news conference is an effort
on his part to cite the things the
administration has indeed achieved i
mean they did if they had a 1.9 trillion
covert relief bill he got that passed he
had the the infrastructure bill which
was another sizable wad of spending that
was done on a bipartisan basis he can
certainly point to that those two things
are real and not insignificant his
problem i think of course is that
all these matters that relate to covid
have not ended up ending covet which he
promised to do as you pointed out
and on the economic side uh
you know the fact that the economy is
growing and it certainly has been and
continues to stock market up and all the
rest of it
much of that is obscured by the fact
that every single american is feeling
the effects of inflation which is
spurted forward in a way we haven't seen
in many many years indeed so he's got a
problem but he does have some things he
can point to and i think we'll hear more
about what he has done than promises to
do better on what he hasn't done and
it'll be interesting to see if he wants
to make any kind of a turn away from his
allegiance to his party's left that has
so dominated the first year in office
that's an interesting point i i get my
assessment britain and help me out let
me know if you if you think this
could work or is conceivable he probably
can't move away from uh his his marriage
with the far left that's that's happened
he's he's he's in on that but what if is
there any chance that a joe 2.0 would
say you know what we're turning the
corner on covet a little bit here we're
gonna we're gonna move into an
environment where we recognize natural
immunity where we don't do mandates
where we don't lock down where we get
kids back into school where we recognize
we're going to have to live with this
maybe
he wouldn't even have to admit he's
wrong he would just have to say we're
entering a new faith at which point
people can breathe again a little bit
business goes back to normal life goes
back to normal people might like that
heading into well i think people might
indeed like that but remember for him to
say the things that you just outlined
would be for him to contradict much of
the policies that he has adopted and
many of which are still in place it
seems to me what he would need to do
would be to announce a whole set
of policy changes in which he'd be
overruling um people like dr fauci and
and his cdc director and so on and i you
know i think that would be that would be
a hard move for him to make at this time
this kind of thing though pete has been
done i mean bill clinton had a very
rough start and lost control of congress
lost control of the house of
representatives for the first time in
decades
uh in the election in 1992
i mean 1994 that was a huge deal
and uh he made a he did a real a real
shift at that time and he became the
more moderate bill clinton who'd been
the governor of arkansas
rather than the lefty one we'd seen for
his first year in office but that was
only after a big
washout at the polls whose message was
unmistakable i suspect that many in the
binding administration are still
clinging to the hope that they can turn
things around in the second year and
avoid that kind of calamity that clinton
faced in 1994.
interesting very interesting point i
wonder if we'll maybe we'll hear joe
biden utter those words the era of big
government
is over i i i don't feel like we will
but that would be an interesting joe 2.0
echoing echoing uh bill clinton britt
hume thank you so much for your time
appreciate it wise words hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else